creed
yes sir everything okay everything's
cool dude
yeah why do you have the big picture up
again you used that already when you
burned your foot
we're using the ben kingsley too i was
going to put up some
new pictures but um all of the ink in
the printer was gone
that's interesting wow it's a little
early for ice cream
it's never too early for ice cream gem
but we didn't have any ice cream
so this is mayonnaise and black olives
oh it's comfort food all right
my mind is going a mile an hour that
fast oh
yo this is his new chair no he hasn't
picked one yet
dad when pam gets michael's little chair
i get pam's old chair then i'll have two
chairs
only one to go and as of this morning we
are completely wireless here at schrute
farms
but as soon as i find out where mo's hit
all the wires we'll get that power back
on
all righty what do you want
to give you this oh what
is that it's a feral barn cat i trapped
him last night and i'm giving him to you
as a replacement cat for the one i
destroyed
her name was sprinkles and his name
is garbage mose calls him garbage
because he likes to eat garbage
don't you garbage uh i can't believe you
just thought you could replace sprinkles
before she's even in the ground you
haven't buried her yet
don't rush me i'm grieving garbage can
be very helpful
okay he's a useful cat he killed an
entire family of raccoons look at him
i don't want garbage i want sprinkles
i left a little present for angela i
think she's going to like it
because i found it outside vance
refrigeration all alone
and i told her in the note that the cat
came to find her
that they were destined to be together
i got game hmm
see how relaxed i am i like this chair
offers good support it is ergonomically
correct kelly you're here
hey ryan hey whose baby is this
oh are you like a manny now no this
little guy is mine
so i was dating this girl and one day
she went out to get a new charger for
her e-cigarette
never came back hold the story in the
book
[Music]
i got you some tiramisu no hard feelings
oh
good stuff
you look really pretty thank you michael
david i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm eating turmeric we are
spoiled because we throw out
perfectly good tiramisu because it has a
little tiny hair on it
one two three
extraordinary events call for
extraordinary actions
will you form an allegiance to use
sudden violence
do you have the tools to turn a wooden
mop handle into a stake
what size
what i really want honestly michael is
for you to know it so that you can
communicate it to the people here
to your clients to whomever oh okay what
it's whoever not whomever that's
whomever no whomever is never actually
right
well sometimes it's right michael is
right it's a made-up word used to trick
students no
actually whomever is the formal version
of the word
obviously it's a real word but i don't
know when to use it correctly not a
native speaker i know what's right
but i'm not gonna say because you're all
jerks who didn't come see my band last
night do you really know which one is
correct i don't know
it's whom when it's the object of the
sentence and who when is the subject
that sounds right well it sounds right
but is it how did ryan use it as an
object it's an object ryan is me as an
object
is he right about that how did he use it
again it was ryan wanted michael the
subject
to uh explain the computer system the
object to
whomever meaning us the indirect object
which is the
the correct usage of the work no one uh
asked you anything
ever so whoever's name is toby why don't
you take a letter opener and stick it
into your skull
oscar oscar
[Music]
i think i'm gay
[Music]
why do you say that
it's just that i'm so emotional
and i can't no but maybe the wreath okay
[Music]
yes that's it push yourselves boys it's
not a party if you don't do something
that scares you
okay uh number three eat spicy foods
okay the opposite of that
stick spicy food up her butt nope nope
nope nope oh should i bring a dictionary
to the hospital the hospital will
provide dictionaries bring a thesaurus
michael's having a hard time with the
gender part of spanish so
i told him to mark everything with the
international symbol for gender
and um i should have been more specific
has anyone started calling you gabe wod
yet not here no
wow you just dive right in you know
around age 12 i just started going for
it
oh help help what what happened
i fell off the toilet i'm caught
between the toilet on the wall what do
you need
no not you someone else get pam
i think pam's gonna want to come into
the men's room you're ryan
oh he needs to lift me and he needs to
clean me up a little bit
bring a wet towel ryan
is uh dead no he's not i just saw him
now
why don't you just buy the whole song
i don't have to buy it i just want to
taste
my heart
stanley that i have asthma because i
don't if it gets out they won't let me
scuba
if i can't scuba then what's this all
been about
what am i working toward two eyes two
ears
a chin a mouth ten fingers
two nipples a butt two kneecaps a penis
i've just described to you the loch ness
monster
and the reward for its capture all the
riches
in scotland
i don't think it's gonna work out the
way you think i don't think you
get it i love this hog mama dwight said
it's hog ma
what is more never had any problem in
that arena
and i have been with several older men
how old old
jinx buy me some coke no really is there
time to change this
that show i mean first they say that mr
shue doesn't know anything about
choreography
and then like three episodes later he's
this fantastic choreographer
pick a lane people and what was with
jesse's sudden turn on rachel between
dream on and funk where the heck did
that come from
honestly that show it's just it's
irresponsible
lacula dracula
what are you doing i wanted to eat a pig
in a blanket
in a blanket hey
what do you guys have to do hello
you're the man buddy i run a small fake
id
company for my car with a laminating
machine that i swipe from the sheriff
station
do you like tcby who doesn't i can't
believe it's
i can't believe it's yogurt last week i
may have gone too far
i'll explain it quickly basically i
found out where he gets his clothes dry
cleaned custom ordered the same suit
made with tearaway velcro and
you can film the rest
dammit jim
what are you doing what are you doing uh
in the foster home my hair was my room
we need a warning signal we don't need a
warning signal kevin i can see him right
there we do
i promise you we don't need a warning
warning warning warning
morning
you